tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono sani j
e il today we are one happy meals quando
avrà 80 anni spero di smettere di dire
questa frase però mai dire mai ragazza
remo altre miliardesimi episodio di
apple ma non è mai troppo partiamo
ragazzi con rob soccer v 3.0 giusto per
festeggiare la vittoria dell'italia
viva l'italia bene quella è la germania
dopo la partita dei quarti di finale
attenzione pelle per le ipo a cadro e
che gol che fa l'ho fatto va bene
[Musica]
ai ragazzi dico la verità giocherei a
sta roba a vita cioè i giochi di calcio
sua piece di giocare tutta la vita non
so perché mi piacciono troppo solo che
poi in poi risultare ripetitivo il video
ma sono tipo droga youth ultima detto ok
io sto scavalcando dei cactus qualcuno
aspetta che un cammello mi ha appena
[ __ ] un piede spiegatemi zio nei
quattro non rompere i [ __ ] rida melo
ma cos'è sta roba è un poco jump con i
cammelli dai fratello forza perfetto
sulla gobba no ad hoc e male a [ __ ]
male e va bene più male di così sono
lasciamolo qui facciamo finta di non
aver visto sto livello frisell trovo più
bonus
ok the blocks avevo lancia e vabbè un
attimo luca è la madonna
l'ultimo grazie luke sei sempre il
solito stronzo ragazzi non l'hai non
aveva ben capito come fare sta roba che
ero partito malissimo
adesso un dito ancora peggio cam ignota
perfetto dai l'ultima ce la faccio
devi crepare male ho vinto stavolta ho
vinto non si sa come ma ho vinto bella
sa già che c'è anche il bonus sisto
livello hanno fatto due livelli in uno
baffigo
sarebbe una sorta di palla da
demolizione per camion
va bene la mia vita sta pian piano
acquistando un senso ragazzi però volevo
solo dirlo adesso riprende bene io ho
comprato un frullato come direbbe
merluzzo cotto è frullato sfera bene ho
finito e stato bello veramente sono
contento esco di casa col sorriso
stampato in faccia
pongo versus missili ai poco dolce al 10
si mattioli l'inglese dovresti imparare
a utilizzarlo chiaramente non lo sai ma
non conosci manco per sbaglio madonna
costo schivato ce l'ho fatta lo scriva
tipicamente tutti credo è porca [ __ ]
stanno scherzando marche culo che
gollismo dimmi che era l'ultimo lo
sapevo che alla lazio sollecita a morir
all'ultimo c'è come come cazzo si fa the
impossible
ce la possiamo fare ragazzi me lo sento
solo che hanno queste la colori tavolino
ed altra volta che tra l'altro ha fatto
su bello come morire no vabbè adesso ci
riprovo giusto per la soddisfazione di
riuscirci sempre ragazzi bene avete
visto come sono bravo senti però
quell'angolino li di livello e ti ti ti
ti fa comodo oppure è un caso che
finisce sempre così va bene ci riprovo
ragazzi è difficilissimo non mi
ricordavo che fosse
di sicuro ci ha messo meno l'altra volta
di e vabbè quanto che calcio gli occhi
lato ragazzi incredibile ho fatto una
cosa incredibile
ci sono ci sono il solo ci sono ci sono
atti le risorse gol ball vale come
vittoria mi affido alla palla per questo
perché veramente non ci sto facendo man
games welcome to my live this is my
brand new mini games che si va bene ho
capito a e l'impiccato giusto choose the
one of the cloud e rosso o verde
questo l'inizio allora e rosso verde
cos'è rossoverde la bandiera dell'italia
non so g sbagliato di le vocali locali a
colla ovviamente sarà in inglese
cos'è rossoverde che inizia con la rai a
è ok inizia con la e finisce con lei è
fantastico amore amore l'amore in rosso
e verde dipende dai cuori di whatsapp
che mandi r affanculo n è inesistente st
parola b ma sei [ __ ] tu e tua sorella
perché è impossibile allora se li
facciamo e rosso verde e p apple mela e
non è vero e bianca succhia è rob swing
12 deserto eco rops indecenti da è da
una vita che non ne faccio e lo vedo
proprio lampante il motivo
ma scusa mi dovevo passare nel verde non
c'è ci sono arrivato prima sul verde non
è passato
kami nota l'aidaa ora che è impossibile
ma torna che casino non sta diventando
impossibile ragazzi giocare è più i
soldi
tutti 2 nell'anno insieme alla mela ti
infili oppure quella ho sbagliato a
farlo per in teoria doveva entrare nel
punto verde ma va bene lord of staff un
sacco di roba mica già un livello che si
chiama un sacco di roba mi fa paura
provata una tisana quando hai tempo puoi
farcela è se vuoi quanto lì ogni oggetto
quando fanno così dio è la cosa che
voglio di più ragazzi non credo di aver
mai fatto un livello così perché gli
taglio sempre perché li odio quando ci
sono soggetti li detesto smartphone sono
forte no vabbè ragazzi degli spy phone
non li so fare
scherzavo stavo veramente scherzando non
prendetemi sul serio o facciamo questo
201 sport.ro decente con le angurie mi
mancava questa veramente con la queen
sono scarso e vabbè vabbè non ci credo
ma non ci posso credere non azzeccata
una
ok una si è bebè manca tutto il resto
provo a fare una roba storta ma non ce
la farò mai complimenti fa vj sono un
prodigio di degli world trovo veramente
sono troppo forte addio santo quanto è
difficile sta diventando è più
sicuramente sto trovando difficoltà a
fare i livelli base di regia di ryder
sarebbe quel gioco preferiresti vi
ricordate quale tra le due cose
preferiresti fare preferiresti cambiare
il tuo cognome in hitler o non mangiare
più la cioccolata lorenzo hitler non so
come no kat sventa
in realtà fa cagare la cioccolata quindi
avrei scelto anche la cioccolata
volentieri ma c'è cascato lui
preferiresti non avere internet o non
avere il telefono non avere internet non
scaccia lo spettro mi chiami sono come
se fosse questione di vita o di morte ho
lasciato proprio il mio mezzo
preferiresti che nessuno si presentasse
al tuo matrimonio o che nessuno si
presentasse al tuo funerale al mio
funerale ma che cazzo ne frega sostò
morto e [ __ ]
sono contento grazie easyfold facciamo
queste ragazze che mi sembra più easy
folle mi stava incastrando all'inizio
pensate voi come sto messo dai che è
facile ecco questo è il livello che
riesce a fare solo se sei malgaro tipo
come me o se mangi tanta vitasnella
bravo a zio abita snella vai
ecco più che vitasnella adesso è morto e
snella mi sa proprio dai veloce veloce
ma ci passa neanche il bifidus aiuta in
questi momenti come ho fatto a morire mi
sono beccato uno spuntone nel momento
più sbagliato della vita non possono
fare gli ascensori per chi non è capace
ok non mi intasate il varco alla fine
che devo passare grazie
ok l'ho fatta
ero più magro in questo tentativo che in
quello di prima perché ho provato ab
rocket quello che vendono su
mediashopping perché se lo ricorda be
rock non ricordo solo io just do it
va bene non ci credo non ci posso
credere ho fatto savage dalle onde
spacebar enright ero key to love
non ho capito niente vi giuro 0 a ok
sono forte
ho vinto a loro mandarla nel buco che ho
capito dai ragazzi quanto è difficile
sto livello madonna o ci proverò a vita
finché non ci riesco sì ce l'ho fatta
sono forte sono forte ma mi dà la
vittoria
niente scherzavo va bene prova a rubare
la moneta che moneta durban bello non la
voglio più rubare st moneta non mi piace
ed è la mina fermi un attimo clausen
afghano se riuscissi ecco perfetto ma
non ci credo ma come ho fatto a
sbagliare si no si sono riposati ma ora
me li vedete che riesco a morire è ok
perché sarei stato capace di morire vi
giuro per come sono fatto io ed breaker
the face con questo come ultimo che mi
sento io non vorrei mai provare una roba
del genere farebbe ma non è che brutta
sensazione è devo anche arrivare la a
lacco alla moneta sono non è contento va
bene ma i machete tipo il dolore atroce
questa cosa ma come faccio a non
arrivarci dio mio
vado a parlare demolizione proprio anche
me like avrà kimbo besa [ __ ]
[ __ ] brava piano piano piano non
imita 2 mi sono incastrato col culo
vitae vitasnella qua mi sa di no va bene
quell'uomo sta soffrendo
io lo so ma i [ __ ] impossibile
vabbè dai ci riprovo l'ultima volta
l'ultima vera non ti missioni giuro a
corona
si è fatta non ci credo va bene va bene
sono contento peccato raggasonico un
crollo che l'episodio è stato veramente
strano sto episodio di epis ma veramente
tanto strano però che vi sia piaciuto un
mi piace per le colate in faccia che si
è beccato il tizio di prima lasciato
argomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come noi in totale
descrizione sostituisca gli amici vi
davano così o video come al solito bene
ragazzi